-Well, here we are, everybody.
Election day is tomorrow,
and the president has settled
on his closing message --
promising to fire
Dr. Anthony Fauci
and threatening to prematurely
declare victory
and steal the election
through the courts.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We're in the midst
of the worst stretch
of the coronavirus outbreak
since it began,
And the bleak reality will only
get bleaker.
With as many as a thousand
Americans dying a day,
and nearly 100,000 new cases
recorded on Friday alone,
the nation is crying out
for leadership.
And with just one day left in
the most consequential election
Of our lifetimes, the president
has finally settled
on his closing message.
-Like the great Pavarotti, the
singer, when --
you know, he was a very --
he was diva.
He was the greatest
of all divas.
He was an incredible talent with
the most unbelievable voice.
And I've gone to concerts
where he would say,
"No, no, no, no,
I do not feel good.
I will not sing tonight,"
and he'd leave.
See? And then I've gone
to somewhere,
it was the most unbelievable
voice that ever lived.
I mean, the greatest, right?
Pavarotti.
But he was a -- he liked me,
for whatever reason.
He was very terrible
to other people.
To me, he was nice. He liked me.
But he goes, "Donald, Donald,
I will not sing tonight."
He'd have a thousand people.
"I will not sing tonight because
I not feel --
I will leave tonight."
And he'd leave.
"Ladies and gentlemen,
he's just canceled."
But when he was great,
he was great.
-Ah, yes, just what your rally
crowds are interested in --
the entertainment enjoyed
by wealthy New Yorkers.
[ As Trump ] And how about
David Sedaris, folks?
Oh, we love to read his dry,
whimsical essays
on our decks in Bridgehampton.
You know it?
[ Normal voice ]
What was the thinking
behind telling that story?
"Mr. President, polling has you
behind in the rust belt."
[ As Trump ] Don't worry.
I'll do my Pavarotti chunk.
[ Normal voice ] Talking about
Pavarotti at a Trump rally
is like holding a Yo-Yo Ma night
at a monster truck rally.
[ Gruff voice ]
Tonight at Watkins Glen,
say goodbye to Bulldozer and
"cello" to Yo-Yo Monster!
[ Normal voice ] There's so much
to unpack from that clip.
First, I love how Trump says,
"But he liked me
for whatever reason,"
basically admitting that even
Trump doesn't know
why anyone would like him.
Second, no one swings
more wildly between praise
and criticism faster than Trump,
who says Pavarotti is the
greatest in one breath,
and then he was very terrible
to other people in the next.
[ As Trump ]
Pavarotti, voice of an angel,
heart of a calcified turd.
Just a bad guy.
Bad, bad guy.
[ Normal voice ] And third,
Trump supporters will follow
Trump anywhere, but even they
had nothing but blank stares
for that one.
"I know Giuliani and Scaramucci.
Which one is Pavarotti?"
And finally,
was that long-ass story
Trump telling us if he loses,
he'll just walk away
like Pavarotti?
Eh. Probably wishful thinking.
He told it because right before
he went on stage,
he saw a pizza box.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, looks like Pavarotti.
[ Normal voice ]
This is where Trump is at.
His record is so horrendous,
he has nothing to talk about
other than rambling incoherently
about long-dead celebrities who
were nice to him 20 years ago.
In fact, with basically
one day left,
Trump decided that
regaling his crowds
with bizarre backstage
encounters with opera singers
wasn't enough, so he decided
to close out the campaign
by threatening to fire
the nation's
top infectious disease expert,
Dr. Anthony Fauci,
a man whose popularity in polls
far exceeds Trump's.
-Don't tell anybody,
but let me wait
till a little bit
after the election.
-You're going fire one
of the country's most trusted
scientists in the middle
of a pandemic?
Who are you going to replace him
with, zombie Pavarotti?
[ As Trump ] Only the fake news
says he's dead, folks.
We gave him a shot of Regeneron
right in the ass,
and now he is good as new.
Luciano, sing a few bars for us.
[ As Pavarotti ] ♪ Brains-ah!
Give me the brains! ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I can't believe
this is Trump's closing message
for the last day
of the campaign.
Trump says stuff like this
because he doesn't think
he's accountable
to public opinion.
Remember,
he lost the popular vote,
escaped impeachment,
and has never had
a majority approval rating
once in his presidency.
He thinks our anti-Democratic
institutions like the Senate
and the electoral college
and the Supreme Court
will protect him, and he's been
broadcasting as much,
announcing that he'll use
the courts to potentially
steal the election by
prematurely declaring victory
and shutting down the count.
-Axios reported that the
president claims
to declare victory Tuesday night
if he appears to be "ahead."
Of course, some states like
Pennsylvania may well show
early leads for the president
based on the same-day vote.
That would be before mail-in
ballots where Democrats
are expected to have
an advantage in Pennsylvania
are counted.
-I think it's terrible when
we can't know the results
of an election the night
of the election
in a modern day age
of computers.
I think it's a terrible thing.
We're going to go in
the night of.
As soon as that election
is over,
we're going in with our lawyers.
-First of all, do you even have
any lawyers left?
Most of them have quit,
gone to jail,
or have been tricked by Borat.
If you're going to need Rudy
on election night,
give him a head's up now so he
can start tucking in his shirt.
[ As Giuliani ] Hold on.
I gotta lay down on the bed,
then roll onto the floor,
then crawl to the phone
to call someone to help me up.
I usually call my cousin,
AKA, my wife!
[ Laughter ]
Secondly,
you never know the official --
What?
Still works on Shoemaker, guys.
I got a very small sample size
to know these callbacks
are working.
Second, we never know
the official final results
on election night.
Those are just projections based
on partial vote counts.
Election day itself is mostly
an invention of TV
and radio, like jingles.
Before radio and TV,
no one ever gave you
their telephone number via song.
"Can I call you some time?"
"Sure. My number is
♪ K-A-R-S, Kars For Kids" ♪
"You know what? Just say no.
If you don't want me
to call you, just say no."
The actual votes are tallied
and then certified
days or weeks
after the election,
and then the electoral college
meets in December
to make it official.
That's always how it's worked.
That's why presidential
inaugurations
used to be in March.
Back in the day, it took so long
to find out who won,
one guy became President
and then immediately died.
Somebody should do a musical
about that guy.
♪ My name
is William Henry Harrison ♪
Oh [bleep] it works.
Oh, Broadway, here we come.
What? Why not?
Closed, why?
Oh, right. The pandemic.
-[ Laughs ]
-they're making their strategy
as clear as they can.
Republicans have been in court
desperately trying to throw out
ballots in states like Texas,
Wisconsin,
Minnesota, and Pennsylvania.
They're not just saying
the quiet part loud.
They're screaming it.
On Sunday,
Trump campaign officials
and overinflated football
Jason Miller lied about the vote
counting process
and said that if Trump seems to
be ahead on election night,
he'll prematurely declare
victory and try to stop
the remaining ballots
from being counted.
-If you speak with many
smart Democrats,
they believe that
President Trump will be ahead
on election night, probably
getting 280 electorals,
somewhere in that range,
and then they're going try
to steal it back after
the election.
-By steal it back, you mean
count all the votes,
you Funko Pop!?
There is no magic cutoff where
you guys get to suddenly
just decide the election
is over.
If you could just declare
yourself the winner
whenever you're ahead,
the jets wouldn't be 0-8.
They would be a still terrible
2-6.
TV news networks have to be
careful with this
because it's extremely
dangerous.
We have to be prepared
as a nation
for early returns in places like
Pennsylvania, Michigan,
Wisconsin, and Minnesota
to differ significantly
from final vote tallies
as mail ballots are counted.
Even if Biden wins Pennsylvania
by five points,
as the polls currently suggest,
a disproportionate number
of Democratic mail-in votes
means we could be in a situation
where trump is ahead by as much
as 16 points on election night.
And if that happens, you know
he is going to run out onstage
and declare himself the winner
and barricade himself
in the White House with
a year's supply of Diet Coke
and three to five Melanias.
[ As Trump ] My favorite
is Morpheus Melania.
And my least favorite is the one
who won't hold my hand!
[ Normal voice ] Which is why
if Trump decides to just
declare victory, TV networks
should refuse to air it,
or at the very least make clear
that it's meaningless.
You can't just declare yourself
President
any more than I can go to
the mall
and declare my dad New
Hampshire's sexiest man.
Though, tell me I'm wrong.
There is virtually no dispute
about who is actually going to
win more votes.
So this is all Trump and his
allies have left -- cheating.
The president and Republican
party have left the nation
in tatters after four years of
crisis, incompetence, and greed,
so they have nothing to run on,
which is why they built
their entire campaign strategy
around whipping up fear
and calling anyone who opposes
them an angry mob.
-It is clear the media mob
is full of liars.
The media mob, of course,
aiding and abetting
and protecting fragile Joe.
-They have decided to be
activists for the left-wing mob.
-Right now the mob has a voice
in the Democrat Party.
-Joe Biden capitulated to
the radical left-wing mob.
-Biden's strategy is to
surrender to the left-wing mob.
He wants to surrender
your nation
to the radical left-wing mob.
There is only one thing standing
between your family
and the radical left-wing mob.
-First of all, I'm not sure
I would use the word "mob"
when your guy dresses like
he just got done
strangling Luca Brasi.
Looks like he's about to pour
kerosene on an informant
tied up in the basement.
[ As Trump ] So hard
to get the smell of gas
out of fine Italian leather.
And have I Pavarotti tickets
tonight.
He likes me,
for whatever reason.
[ Normal voice ] But the reality
of course is the Trump
and his allies don't hate mobs
at all.
In fact, they like them plenty
when they're the ones
forming the mob, as we saw
in Texas on Friday.
-A campaign confrontation
on a Texas highway.
A caravan of President Trump
supporters
surrounded a Biden-Harris bus
as it was traveling
from San Antonio to Austin
Friday.
A Biden campaign official says
the vehicles tried to slow
the bus down and even
push it off the road.
-911 was called by people inside
the bus,
and tonight the FBI has
confirmed to NBC News
it is investigating that
incident.
-The President just moments
ago tweeted this in reply.
-There is a Biden bus,
and it's surrounded
by pickup trucks on a highway,
all with Trump signs.
I mean, it is ordinary Americans
just taking this election
into their own hands.
-Listen, I saw yesterday a
video of these people in Texas.
Did you see it?
All the cars on the road.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love what they did, but here
is the thing they don't know.
We do that in Florida every day.
-You see the way our people,
they were protecting
this bus yesterday,
because they're nice.
-Yeah, sure, they were
protecting the bus.
The same way a loan shark
helps you find your wallet.
Cool shout out to his home state
from Rubio there --
Florida, we also
terrorize our buses!
I mean, my God, this guy.
"How did I do, Mr. President?
You like my speech?"
[ As Trump ]
[Bleep] off, little Marco.
Have some respect for yourself.
[ Laughter ]
The constant cheating,
threats of physical violence,
in addition to be terrifying,
it's also exhausting,
which is why we've all been
anxiously awaiting this moment
for four years,
and for that reason,
it feels surreal
to finally be here.
I probably started thinking
about the 2020 election
the moment Trump was declared
the winner in 2016.
And judging from Trump's face
that night, I wasn't alone.
Wow, it's like when the teacher
says "Oral reports are today,
and just for kicks, let's go
in reverse alphabetical order."
That's him after he asked...
[ As Trump ] Oh, God.
How long is this job anyway?
A months? Six weeks?
Four years?!
Is that human years,
or dog years?
Before you answer, which one
is longer?
[ Normal voice ] And now
we're finally here,
and the final days of Trump's
campaign has predictably
turned vicious and ugly
with his supporters
calling for virtually anyone
who opposes Trump
to be in prison from Joe Biden
to Hillary Clinton
to Gretchen Whitmer,
to Ilhan Omar.
-Joe Biden is a corrupt
politician
who bought and is paid for.
Look, he is bought and paid for
by China.
How about his son?
His son walks in.
He is supposed to be fair.
This place was a mess
four years ago, and frankly,
if your governor opened up
your state --
[ Crowd booing ]
You think Ilhan Omar,
that's one of the reasons
we're going win Minnesota,
because of Ilhan Omar.
Didn't she harvest?
I heard she ballot harvested,
didn't she?
So where is
our justice department?
In fact crazy Hillary,
crooked Hillary came in.
[ Crowd booing ]
Here we go. Watch.
There we go.
They always blame me.
Whenever that chant starts,
all I do is I mention her name.
-But, sure, the Democrats
are an angry mob.
There is only one side in this
race that encourages
their supporters to scream
"Lock them up!"
about anyone they don't like.
They sound like
they should be holding torches
and chasing Frankenstein.
"Lock him up in the castle
with Zombie Pavarotti!"
At what point can we just call
this fascism?
And by the way, to the people
who think calling Trump
a fascist is left-wing hysteria,
you can be a fascist without
being Hitler or Mussolini
the same way you can be
a basketball player
without being LeBron James
or Michael Jordan
or, hell, Barack Obama.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-Nothing summarizes
the Democrats right now
more than that clip.
"Yeah, that's our guy!"
"The one who made the shot?"
"No, no, the "All net" guy.
"Oh. That's good, too."
Anyway, the point is
the president is closing out
an ugly and vicious four years
of the series
of ugly and vicious rallies.
But when he is not revved up,
calling for the imprisonment
of his political opponents
or for valid votes to be tossed
out,
he seems to lose a lot of steam.
Pennsylvania on Saturday, he was
so, dare I say, low energy,
he almost seemed like a man
who knew he was going to lose.
-[ Hoarse voice ]
They hate what they're seeing
because they're not looking at
fake suppression polls anymore.
Now they're looking at the
numbers that are pouring in.
And they don't like the numbers
that they're seeing
in Florida and in Ohio
and in North Carolina.
It could have been
the greatest --
You know, if you look,
we look at the amount of money
that he has raised.
Hundreds of millions,
$300 million one month.
But I could have been
the greatest of all time.
-Yeesh! Did he eat
an entire Thanksgiving turkey
before the speech?
Was it cooked?
He sounds like your burnt out
uncle falling asleep
on the couch
of the Lions-Bears game.
[ As Trump, sleepy voice ]
You know I played football
in high school.
I was going to go pro until
I broke my tailbone
in a butt-chugging accident.
Could have been the greatest
of all ti...
all time.
[ Normal voice ] Look, I get it.
Trump is tired. We all are.
One of the many things you
can say about the Trump era
and about this campaign
is it's been exhausting.
Just four years of constant
crises, late-breaking news,
midnight votes,
and 3:00 a.m. tweets.
In fact, on Friday, Trump
scream-tweeted yet another
incoherent rant which implied
that he wants the Supreme Court
to stop the counting of mail
ballots to help him win.
-President Trump tweeted this
morning that if Biden
is elected, the four justices
that voted in favor
of the ballot extension would be
relegated to sitting on
not only a heavily packed court,
but probably a revolving court.
He said at least the many new
justices will be radical left.
-I don't know what's crazier,
that the president tweeted that
at 2:57 a.m., or the first time
I read "plus1,"
I assumed it was him
trying to spell "Pelosi."
Trump can't run on reality,
so he has to run against it
because the reality is
that after four years
of serial cruelties,
absurdities, lies,
and abusive power,
he's left the nation in ruins.
Half a million new COVID cases
in just one week,
hospital ICUs filling up,
8 million new people in poverty,
a quarter of all households
struggling with food insecurity,
tens of millions facing eviction
and homelessness,
wildfires supercharged
by climate change,
civil unrest over systemic
racism,
protesters brutalized by police,
federal agents tear gassing
protesters
and snatching them
in unmarked cars,
armed right-wing gunmen
patrolling the streets,
migrant families ripped apart,
children who are still missing
their parents to this day,
a postal service near collapse,
weird handshakes and flag hugs,
umbrella ditching
and dance moves
where he looks like a tortoise
flipped on its back,
and a president so soulless
and corrupt he's fought with
Gold Star families,
called war heroes "losers,"
been impeached, had multiple
lawyers, aides,
and campaign chairmen indicted,
faced at least 26 allegations
of sexual assault,
obstructed justice,
broke election laws
by paying hush money
to a porn star,
extorted a foreign country,
had his charity dissolved,
tax returns subpoenaed,
had a secret Chinese bank
account while he was president,
paid $750 in taxes,
and bilked taxpayers
out of $8 million,
including $3
for a glass of water.
Maybe that is why he is always
so careful with it.
[ As Trump ] Can't spill any.
Every drop cost 50 cents!
[ Normal voice ]
And on top of everything else,
he forgot the words
to the national anthem
and "God Bless America."
-♪ What so proudly we hailed ♪
♪ At the twilight's
last gleaming ♪
-♪ Land that I love ♪
♪ Stand beside her
and guide her ♪
-The president
of the United States
sings our most patriotic songs
like a lapsed Catholic
faking their way
through the call and response
at Easter mass.
"In the name of the father,
the son, and the holy spirit.
[ As Trump ] Boo-yah?
[ Whispering ] It's "boo-yah."
Is it not "boo-yah"?
[ Normal voice ] This is it.
This is our chance to put an end
to the cruelty,
the abuses of power,
and the criminal neglect.
Trump incites violence
and threatens to cheat
because he wants us to feel like
he is inevitable,
that he is insulated
from public opinion
and Democratic accountability,
that nothing and no one
can stop him.
Tomorrow is our chance
to prove him wrong.
It's in our power to repudiate
Trump and all he stands for
in overwhelming numbers.
It's our chance
to save our democracy.
And if we succeed,
this time tomorrow,
Trump could very well
be onstage saying...
-I will leave tonight.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask. We love you.